それでは質疑応答の時間にしたいと思うんですけど
はい どうぞ  愚か者のそばにあまりいないようにというお話だったと思うんですが
仕事で職場の上司があの
彼は高学歴で知識はかなり学歴が高くて知識はかなりあるようなんですけれども
上司としては部下に仕事をさせるやり方も全然工夫もないし
どちらかというと仕事の与え方が下手で
同じようなことを何度もやらせるとか
指示が悪くてやり直しを 2回も 3回もやらせるとか
そういう感じの上司の下で今働き始めた状況なんですけれども
このまま自分が続けた方がいいのか
早いうちに見切りをつけた方がいいのか
ちょっと今悩んで  あれは悩まなくても
あれは日本の美徳です
2分でできる仕事なんですけど
これ 3時間かけないとダメなんです
だから それはそちらに一人勝手には帰られません
私はすごい苦労してますけど
外人だからなかなかこれに慣れなくて
みんな同じ日本人同士だからね
だから自分でもまあ 10分でできる仕事でも
やっぱりまあ 30分かけてやってください
何て言うか 勤務時間内だったらばある程度言い返されても
これも仕事のうちなんだろうなと思って諦めてやってるんですけれども
残業っていうのがシステムとしてないんですね
残業それ仕事をうちでやりますと持っていくことできません
できないですし 逆にその定時の 6時を過ぎてから上司が間違ってることに気づいたり
じゃあどうしようっていうのは悩み始めて
昨日も 9時ぐらいまで結局ダラダラ伸ばされて
結局話が決まらずにもう帰りますって
さすがに 9時過ぎたら言えるので
それで帰ってしまったんですけれども
なんかいつまでもこういうことを続けてるのは果たしてどうなんでしょうと思いまして
うーん これはね 上司を直すことはね
私にも無理でしょうしね
知識やら何やらあるならば
もうもう決まって頭が悪いんですよ
この頭が悪い人に勉強できるようなシステムだからね
頭が鋭がすごくて もう物事を自分で一人で考えるならば
日本の試験ではもう落第するんです
英検も同じ 英語を喋るんだったらもうものすごい何回とっても落第しますよ
英語を喋れなくて 決まってるパターンだけ暗記して持っていけば
あの 私もあのコンピューターに作ってる英語を勉強するプログラムあってもう CD で 12枚買い買っちゃったんですけど
面白い 面白いだろうと思ってね
まあ人にあげましたけどね
そこでまあ一応英語は知らなくたってもね
まあそこはもう全部合格できるはずなんですけど
で いろんな質問とかでやってみたんですね
これは何？何？日本語英訳にしようとかね
私にとっては英訳できる方法っていうのはいくつかもあるんですよ
英語っていうのは固く決まってるわけでもないんだからね
いい表現っていうのはいくらでもあります
何 1つも向こうはもう X ですよ
時々すごい格式のあるもうインテリが使う英語で英訳してあげるんです
ダメ それで答えは？と言ったら答え出てきますよ
最悪はれて気持ち悪い
これって英語かと だからやっぱりなるほど頭いい人はもう落第するようにできてるなと
学校でもみんなじゃないんだけど
あの学校を辞めたりすると
すごい頭いい子たちがね
学校大嫌いやとかね もう立場がないんですよ
マンネリでなきゃね みんなやってることをそのままやってる
ない ないとね だからそれも我々個人的にはね
どうすることもできないんですよ
だから 大体日本というのは生活しにくいってことはそういうことです
例えば 1時間でできる仕事に 3時間 6時間かかるとお金もかかるでしょ
それと品物の値段っていうのはね
無茶上がっちゃうでしょうね
人に 1 日分給料払って
その人がやった仕事は手紙 2枚書いただけだったら
その手紙 2枚の値段いくらですかね
それは計算しない なぜならばすごい経済学者だから
みんな 例えば品物を売ってる会社で品物を買ったお客さんに対して礼状を送ると
これは特別な場合で 特別に手紙書いておく
これはこれ間違えて これ間違えて
こここう書く これあれやこと
これ 1 日かかったならば
手紙 2枚に 手紙に場合のお金考えてください
だから外国でね  100円でできることは日本でやっちゃうともう 3,000円になりますよ
それで当然もう最終的に仕事は立派にできますけど
でも私は個人的にはあまり評価できないんですよ
大騒ぎして むちゃくちゃもう時間かけて
ものすごいお金かけて
もうものすごくもう緊張して
神経質で もう病気にまでストレスとことん求めて仕事終わってますけど
仕事はいいんですけど
仕事には文句言うところはないんだけど
どうやって評価するのかと
やって終わってから別に文句つけるところはないんで
仕事は立派ですけどね
だからね こういうところっていうのを直せば
かなり日本はもう本物の豊かになると思いますけどね
これ まあ一応ご自分の仕事だけでもね
あの まあ短時間で短く失敗ないようにという風にした方がね
いいんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
だから私はもう普通ならもうね
まあ 1 日考えて  2 日考えて書かなくちゃいけない文章でも
大体 30分  1時間で書けますけど
書いて終わったらそれはもうレイアウトフォーマットに流してちょうだい頼んだら
これにはもう五 六時間
八時間 二日 三日かかりますからね
やっぱりみんななんか一発で仕事をするのはなんか怯えてるというかね
当然もう慣れてるんだから
一発仕事したらものすごいガタガタなんですよ
やっぱり八回繰り返さないと仕事らしい結果が出てこないんですね
この才能と我々私たち才能というのは
やっぱり短時間で大量の仕事を正しくこなすことですよ
それには才能というと特別な能力が必要なんですよ
なぜならば みんな才能は固定していると思って
みんな固定主観だから
もう世の中で何一つ固定していないんですよ
だからブッダの無常を知っているならば
それで才能なんですよ
で ブッダの無常っていうのは
同じものはね  二度と起こりません
起こる？一つも同じものは二度と起こりません
だから昨日仕事に慣れちゃったんだからといって今日は楽々ということはありえないんです
それでそこは覚えておけば
初めてぶつけた仕事やとね
これどうしようかと でもたくさんやらなくちゃダメだから早くもやらなくちゃいけない
そこでなんとか緊張感みたいなものが
緊張感というよりいい意味の緊張感ですね
いわゆる脳がずっともう回転していると
そこでさっさと見えてくるんですよ
しかし それがまた私に経験があるんだぞと思っちゃうと
アウト もう腐っちゃうんです
だから同じことを二度と現れないということで生きてみれば
もう脳細胞はもうピシピシジリジリと動くんです
だから才能っていうのはもっと特別なことじゃないんです
で 才能っていうのはやっぱりあった方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
本当にもう完璧な才能を育てた場合
育てたい場合は何も勉強しないので
世の中のことは才能開発のためにある本なんかはね
いくらか役に立つかもしれませんだけどね
まず無常であるということはもう徹底的に理解して
心に納得しておくことをね
例えば毎日同じ家族に戻るぞと思ったら
これ違いますよ 一人で生活しているならば問題ないんだけど
家族で生活しているならばね
毎日同じ家に戻るんじゃないんです
そこまで無常で固めると
ものすごく知恵が出てきて
才能も現れてきて 問題なく生きていられます
で もう一つ この脳を動かすためには
やっぱりいつでも軽くて
楽しくいなくちゃいけないんですね
でなきゃ脳は動かないんです
で この苦しくて悔しくて
競争心でね 腹が立ってライバル意識でやらせてるでしょ
アドレナリンばっかり作ってますから
アドレナリンというのはもう体に毒ですよ
猛毒なんです アドレナリンはこのものすごい緊急時は必要かもしれませんだけど
で 別にそうじゃなくて
脳が常に明るくしておけばね
だから笑えば大丈夫ですよ
笑える人間だったらね
もう問題ないんですよ
笑うこともこの人のことを笑うんじゃないんで
これって侮辱ですからね
ただ単にもう人でも誰でもなく
この物事問題 このポイントを押さえて何か笑うというね
冗談見つかるというね
あるいは自分のことを笑うとかね
それを笑えるならば 脳が元気で機能する
そうするとアドレナリンでなく生きていられます
自分の個人の経験というならば
いろいろそんなにたくさんはないんだけど
この大変なことが起きた時はね
もう瞬時に行動しなくちゃいけないとかね
どんな人でもその時すぐ緊張して
もうアドレナリンいっぱい出して動くんですよ
動く人はね バカは止まりますけどね
動く人はしっかりやるんだけど
ものすごいアドレナリンで動いてます
そういう時って自分に合った時は自分の脳がどう動くのか自分がチェックしたところでまるっきり反対なんだよ
動きは反対ということは信じられないほど落ち着くんです
普段はそんな落ち着きないんです
ものすごい細胞一個一個までびっしりと落ち着いているんです
そこで力が出るということは
並じゃない力 もう誰にも及べない
もういくら頑張っても
そのスピードとその速さとその判断力には
その時自動的に脳がもうちゃんと仕事してくれるんです
だから落ち着いてるんだから
仕事終わっても疲れても何ともない
楽しい 普段問題ないでしょうってことで終わっちゃうんです
アドレナリンでやっちゃうと
やっぱり終わったら疲れますよ
すっごく疲れます あの毒をね
体攻撃しますからね だからこのアドレナリンの代わりに別なホルモンを出してね
落ち着きのホルモン出してもらうためには
やっぱり笑うのが一番ですね
それから無常ということでね
才能は出てきますね 才能あれば大体はね
物事はうまく行きますが
まあそういうところで
自分にできる範囲でなんとかやるしかないです
だからそこら辺は能力ないというと明確なんですよ
誰も気にしない 何なのか
例えばゴンさんでしたっけ？あの何会社でしたっけ？あれは
日産 うん だから倒産していたでしょうに
これでたった一人の人間がね
1年で復活させてみせたんだからね
だから同じことを 100回
200回  300回繰り返してやらせるんだから
この車会社だから 普通の手紙 3枚書くほどじゃないでしょうに
お金はね デザインやらそれまた作ってみなくちゃいけないしね
これってものすごいお金かかるでしょうに
だから 一つの決断に来るまでは大体 3ヶ月間ぐらいかかる
ずっとずっと競争で負けるでしょうに
そういうところはもう全部彼が一つ一つ調べて
もう改良したところで
もう黒字に変わってしまったんですね
それでもこの日本の問題っていうのは
この問題があるっていうことに気づかないんですね
ただ アメリカと比較するだけで
根本的に大きな問題があるんですよ
この思考パターンと生活習慣の中で
時間かけた方がかっこいいと思っちゃうしね
この人はこの10年も修行しましたよとか言うと
えらいかっこいいんですね
書道は 書道はね 15年習いましたと
すごいと バカじゃないかなと思いますけどね
私は 1週間しかやって習ってないんだけどと言っていい作品作るんだったらね
すごいでしょうにね だから評価するところはね
かなり違う いつからどうなったか私はあまり調べてないんですけど
なんでそうなったのかと
でもそれもまあいいところはありますよ
そういうもう才能全くないというところは
いいところっていうのは全くダメな人間でも
もう何とかできるようになれます
だって20年ぐらい訓練すればいいんだからね
例えば講習所でもう負けるは負けるは負けるは
それ 20年も頑張って挑戦して
まあ免許を取ったら これまた自分をみんな褒めるんだからね
あんたすごいと そういうわけであの
そういうところを褒めるんだから
やっぱり全くもうもうもう何もできん
もうもうもうゴミみたいな人でも
もう 20年ぐらい頑張ってなんとかちょこっと得ることはできます
それって悪くはないんですよ
やっぱり不幸でかわいそうで生きるよりは
誰でもなんとかできた方がよろしいしね
たったその 1点はいいところで見えますけどね
でも全体的にはそれで社会は困りますよ
もう才能ない人が責任取るということほど恐ろしいことはないんです
それは仏教だったらとんでもない話なんです
ダンマパダに一つ偈があるんですよ
もう阿呆に限って私がやります
私がやりますと いつでも出るんだよと
もう才能ある人というのは私がやりますと言わないんだからね
だからもうこれってとんでもない
マメワカタマンニャントゥ ギヒパッバジタウソッとボッとダンマパダにありますけどね
マメワティパサッスゥ ギッチャ キッミ スキッミチ イティバラスサンカッポ
と 何でしたっけ？なんたかなんとかと
長い偈ですけど 本当は才能ある人は仕事した方がみんな幸せで無事無難で生きていられますよ
二十年訓練してね 何か仕事に就くよりは
自分の才能でできるところで仕事をしてもらった方が
本人にもみんなにも役に立ちますけどね
だから ビルの掃除ぐらいできるならば
それは完璧にしてもらえばいいんですよ
もうとにかく訓練して
訓練して 勉強して 勉強して
ビルの管理者になってやるぞと
それで試験はもうもうもう十回も受けて
十回ももうやっと十一回目で
もう管理の資格取ったとかね
やっぱり危ないんですよ
管理してもらわない方がいいんですよ
その人は楽々だから じゃあビルの掃除やりますと
やればいいのにね 余計なことを考えないで
その方が本人にも社会にも助かりますしね
だから もうなんでこんな風にシステムになって固定化して
これまた美徳としてね
自慢するところまでになったのかということは
私はそういうところはあまり考えてないんです
だからみんな言ってること同じですよ
会社に行ったらあれやこれやとどんな会社でも同じですよ
嫌だったら外人がやってる会社にとにかく仕事を変えてください
でもインド人がやってるんだったら気をつけてくれ
インド人っていうのは自分で仕事しないととにかく他人にやらせるんです
とにかく他人にやらせて自分が遊んでるんです
で 他の人っていうのはそこまではないんです
だからまあ こんな産業までして嫌と思うならば
まあ外国人の会社にやるしかないんです
外国系の その場合 産業はなし
その前にいっぱい仕事しなくちゃいけないんです
繰り返しちゃうと もうその世界ではダメ
危ない だから一つっていうのは
この自分に仕事を与える前に
この自分に与えたデータはしっかりしているのかっていうことはね
何回も確認させちゃえば
先に向こうにね それでは仕事は早いんです
それは私は日本人に対して私がやる態度なんですね
時間取って散々いじめて
もうもう苦労させてやるった態度を取ると
私はそれを逆に回してもらいます
で こちらは楽々をするんです
例えば資料を出す場合でも
あれも必要 これも必要
あれもあれもこうと これは何回
何回言うんだからね 先に聞くんです
どれぐらいですかと で
書いてもらうんです それで出しちゃえば一発でOKということになるんです
話何のことなく いろんなところでね
もうこれは無理あれやとか言って言う場合は
私はそうではなくて どうすればいいんですかね
この場合はと 言うと言ってくれます
ではお願いしますと で
二週間かかる仕事は三分で終わると
まあそれもね ケースバイケースだからね
いつでもということでもないんですけどね
[笑い]繰り返すの好きみたいね
何かに資料出したら これはもう
もうこういうこういうもの揃ってないんだからもう返しますとか
また出してくださいとかね
また また返します また出す
それで十回ぐらい繰り返してもらうのが好きみたい
で 向こうも十回も資料審査しなくちゃいけないってことを覚えてないんですね
だから人をいじめる場合は
自分も一緒にいじめられるってことは知らないんです
そういうのはね 大変ですよ
もうなかなかね ものすごい締まりが良くないんですね
すっごく自分の時良くない
それやろうとするとすごく嫌われるんです
だからもう極力我々みたいなもう外の人間っていうのは極力手話をしないと
我々ももう瞬時に全部もう整理整頓決まっちゃうんですね
自分の部屋は別ですけど
それ以外はね 物事はびっしり決まるんですけどね
日本は住んでる部屋はしっかり整理整頓してますけど
頭は逆 まあ私自身はやっぱりあえて部屋やらね
自分住んでる環境っていうのはだらしない方にした方にしておくんですね
その方が生きているところだから
やっぱり人間生命だからね
ファジーでデジタルじゃないんだからね
だから仕事やら ああそれはデジタル的でね
もうしっかりしないんですけど
生きるっていうことはね
すごいファジーというかね
なんかアナログですね
だから必ずしもボールペンは置いておく場所においておいたら便利ことは確かに便利なんですけど
もうなんか書いてて 何かそのままで放っておいて
別なことに行って あれどこへ行ったのかな？どこへ隠れたんですか？ボールペンはとか
それは普通の生の生き方の場合はそういう風なアナログなんですけど
仕事の世界はまた別にしなくちゃね
これは答えはないということで
すいません すいません
門下における師弟関係についてちょっとお尋ねしたいんですが
一回弟子入りした弟子っていうのは
師匠の方からもう出て行けっていう
そういうことは言えないとかないんですか？そういうことは
あんまり言わないんですけどね
カッサバ調のほどの方が
その自分の身の危険を感じるような状態でも
アデリソンはずっとその育てをこさ-だからそれはそこまでは余計なこと言えんで
カッサパ長老はそれだったら知ってるんだったら計画立ててるんだし
それは考えてもなかったでしょうね
突然どうか放火されただけのことでね
誰も知らない 子供が自分を殺そうとしてるんだったら
もう逃げるでしょうに
知らないでしょ そんなの知らないでしょ
はい もうて 日本でもしょっちゅうそういう事件が起こるでしょうね
もう一番最近なのはね
なんか子供がね 家に自分の家を放火しちゃってね
赤ちゃんも死んじゃってというね
別にまあ本人もただ腹が立ってだけで
もうなんかやりたかっただけのことやと思いますけどね
結果としてはそこまでなってるし
そこまで父は知っていたならばね
言わないで学校に行け
学校に行け あれやこれやとかね
もっと親切にした方がこの子は
でなきゃ家放火するもするかもしれませんけど
誰がそんなことを うちの息子はね
まあこんなこと言ったらもうみんな殺すかもしれません
だから気をつけましょうとかね
思わないでしょ 人間の世界ってそういうことだから分かりません
事件が起きてから分かったって意味もないしね
それは避ける方法もないんです
一応先には読み取れますけど
仏教の世界ではね その場合はもうそれでも答えがないんですよ
仏教の世界ではね まあ弟子が性格悪いんだったらね
もうもう指導しない それだけ
トラブルは起こさない
例えば朝早く起きないで指導しないんだと
指導する人だったら 朝起きなかったらね
もうとんでもないことしますけど
まあ指導しないことになったら
朝起きなくたっても別にどうったことはないし
で 遅く起きてきたっても
もう何のこともないし
座る場所を用意するだけでね
本人もおそらく無知だから気付かないでしょ
私の場所ちゃんと用意しているんだとかね
すごく胸張ってくるでしょ
その場合は でも本当は捨てられてますけど
それで もう食べ物やらそういうことはものすごいしっかり用意しておくし
さらに胸張るんですね
私は好きな時時間に行ったら全部店長が用意してるけど
用意してなかったらなんでないかということになるでしょうしね
なんかすごい親切やと勘違いするんです
これはまあもともと無知な愚か者だからね
本人に罪は犯さないようにとちょこっとガードしてるんです
それは無視することでやるんです
無視するんだからといって
ご飯まで用意してあげないということはしません
全部人間として 生命として必要なことは全部やってあげる
しかしアドバイスはしない
それでも何か危険なことする可能性はあります
スリランカでもありますよ
お坊さんの中でもね お坊さん殺されたというね
ケースあります だから弟子が性格
弟子がお坊さん殺した
これ人殺しも悪い世界でね
仏教でも出家までして言うと殺しちゃうとお坊さん考えられないことでしょ？どれほど性格悪いかと
それぐらいのこと知ってるんですけどね
具体計とかはないんです
今 そんなところですよ
まあいちいちアドバイスはしないんですね
それはまあ物語の中でもね
そういう内容となってますからね
アドバイスしたところで大変な危険なことになります
それが両側にも危険なんですね
アドバイスした側にも危険し
した側にも危険なんです
そこで逆にね 道徳の中ではね
まあそれには何かエピソードはない
あるとは思いますけど
思い出せませんだけど
人間にとって一番損損はもう目上の人から見放されることなんです
あるアドバイスしないことなんです
それほど損がないんだと
人間というのは教えてもらって育てる生命だから
躾ないと成長しない生き物ですからね
だから付き合いっていうことはもう呼吸と同じ大事なんです
それで一緒にいても教えてくれないんだったら
まあそれはすごい損なんです
俗世間といった俗人の場合はね
まあケチで教えてくれない時もありますけど
その場合は師匠いてもないんだからね
その場合は師匠から自分離れるんです
この人と一緒にいても
私には何の成長もありませんと
親切で教えてる先生なのに
まあ自分が性格悪いんだったら
自分から出て行くこともないし
危険なことにもなります
とにかく性格悪い人にはアドバイスしてはならないというジャータカ物語ってありますか？かなりあります
王様の話もありましてね
王様がこの あるこれジャータカでね
ある王様がこの猿を 一匹を飼ってね
猿がすごく気に入っちゃって
で すごく二人で仲良し
で まあ猿でも雄だったらかなり凶暴ですからね
まあもう王様をもうすごくもう守ってるんですね
一人でいる時はもう猿と一緒にいるし
他の人が入ろうと思っちゃうと
もう凶暴で攻撃するし
これではよかったと 人間は信頼できないからね
こいつはもう誰か私を暗殺しようでも来たらもう噛み付くんだから
それでもう命守れますよと
猿をすごい信頼していたんだ
それでどこかあの遊びに行って
でっかい公園で遊んで昼寝したかったんだと
昼寝したっても 途中で誰かがもう隠れてきてね
暗殺したら大変だからね
一応周りみんな警備をね
遠いところへ置いておいて
自分の軍隊も近寄らないところに入れておいて
昼寝している猿と一緒に
猿はいつもそば 飼っているペットだから
猿も真面目 一応 王様が寝たんだから
じゃあ俺の仕事やっていうことでも寝ない
猿どうせ昼は寝ないんだからね
待ってるんですね 誰か来たらもうタダですまんそうと
とにかく王様の肩の猿を持ってるんです
これでハエが来てブーブーって鳴きながらもう回ってるんですね
猿がこれを怒ったんですね
邪魔するなよと ハエっていうのは一応もう止まっちゃうでしょうね
ちょうど王様の体の上に止まっちゃったんです
猿はカッとなって思いっきりハエを切っちゃったんです
それで王様は終わりと
猿は全然悪いことしてないんです
もうハエを切っちゃった
王様の昼寝邪魔するなよと
そのエピソードも愚か者の嘘つき
信頼するなと 気持ちはあれやこれやと言ってもね
猿の気持ちは悪くないでしょ
すごい立派なペットとして
でも余計に信頼するとリミットがありますと
それで似てるもう一つエピソードがありまして
今時間ないんですけど
これ私よく子供頃ね よくよく言われたんですけどね
愚か者の問題ということでね
同じことで殺されたということでね
その場合は父親は大工さんで息子と一緒にいて
息子はバカで ですけど父親の子だからね
父親のことをすごい大事にしているし
で 父親が大工道具を持って一生懸命仕事をしていると
もう頭に蚊が来て止まって刺し始めたんだと
で 息子に「蚊がもう刺してますけど
追い出してください」と
息子はすごく怒っちゃって
もう私の頭に何するのかと言って
黄色い斧 斧でしたっけ？ありましたから 「
お前 てめえ何や」と言って思い存分頭に殴って
もう蚊を切っちゃったんですけどね
父親の頭の上に止まっている
それで頭二つになりましたと
蚊は逃げたと だからそれでたとえ息子でもね
愚か者に気をつけるというね
そういうふうにエピソードあるんだから
私たちにとっては道徳っていうのはすごい生活と一緒になったってね
まああんまりそんなに大したことじゃないんです
物語文化っていうのはすごい楽なんですよ
昔 私は自分の友達みたいに
いくらか社会的なね 同じレベルの人々としか付き合いませんだから
我々は一時間 二時間 三時間いて
みんなお互いにストーリー言い合ったりするんですよ
それまた上手下手がありますからね
上手な人いるともう次から次へとストーリーの連発で
すごい楽しいんです 時々あまりにも面白いんだったら
プレゼンテーションの方に「あれもう一度言いなさいよ」とね
またもう一度言ったりする
落ちやらね それすごい綺麗に
もう大体友達とは世間話とか何とかもうほとんどしないんです
気持ち悪いしね たまに会う人だったらいろいろ喋りますけど
仲良くしている人々とは全然世間話
政治話 全然なし ストーリーの競争ですね
だから我々はあまりカッコつけませんよ
いい大人にしてよく男話聞いてる範囲で
それはカッコつけません
これはもうカッコいいと
面白く言えるのが勝っていうね
はい では時間三十分も過ぎましたので終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
じゃあ散会します